[Music]
you are working on new music I hear it's
good it's almost finished
it just was time to get him done and get
in the studio so did you write all like
everything on the project I wrote three
of the four okay I was and it might be
five actually wrote one just recently
that's pretty it's almost little savage
a little little yeah it's a little raw
emotionally so I'm like I might have to
throw that guy in there but based on
personal so I know you've had some
changes in your life yeah yeah it was
very personal but it was one of those
sessions where like I was like I can't I
literally can't write about anything
else today this I have to write this
because it's all I can think about and
it's been a hard day so I got it out of
the song and it's just such a it was
such a raw moment and I would love to
incorporate that song into like this
group that I'm gonna take around so it
just it's just very symbolic and shows
where I am in my life and that's
important to me
how are you doing new single Cassidy how
is this new chapter treating you it's
good I mean it's super uncomfortable
it's super risky and weird but it's also
really exciting and I feel just this
kind of I don't know I feel like the
town is cheering me on which is really
cool I've been in a lot of sessions I've
just been calling on a lot of friends
and everybody's been there for me so
it's a weird time but it's also really
exciting I'm excited to see what happens
have your girlfriend's been getting you
through yeah yeah oh my gosh I've
actually I mean Lindsey Elle is a good
friend I've leaned on some songwriter
friends and yeah I mean my mom and
sister have been amazing so I mean it's
not all that it's some awesome stuff to
like the music steps is really exciting
you